now during this time all I wanted in
life I wanted to be a professional
soccer player so all my time was devoted
to playing soccer and so like you know I
I got signed professionally
um as a backup goalkeeper when I was 16.
it was quite young yeah for like a big
league right it was in frustrated at the
time yeah it was the national league and
um and Adelaide Adelaide city Adelaide
City mate we were doing that right
before he came like and like Brisbane
City Gold Coast Melbourne
Adelaide you know we get into Adelaide
everyone just like you know that's like
uh most serial most serial killers per
capita in the world Adelaide Adelaide
but it's got lovely Parks I've been
there twice have you yeah did you know
about the serial killer I didn't I won't
be returning no go ahead the Taurus
River used to have floaters going down
at all the time
it's interesting because my wife came
with me my my current wife came with me
I call it my current wife because you
never know and uh my future ex-wife my
future ex I don't think so no it's just
current and uh she's such a good sport
you know she came to Adelaide with me
because I was doing something there and
um
she was without me saying anything
she said I work for a bit of a run down
by the by the
the river
the the tar what's the river called I
forget now the Torrance no I don't know
but it goes through the city and there's
all this listen it's also one of the
most beautifully planned cities Parks
everywhere anyway this city this river
runs through the middle of it and um
there's a particular part of it that has
a pretty dark history
and she would say to me I don't know
what it is I don't like running down
there because it just kind of creeps me
out there's something there I said you
have good instincts many people have
floated right past that bridge
oh my god there was a spade of of of
murders especially of young boys Jesus a
massive amount
um one of the greatest unsolved cases in
Australian history still not solved this
is a case called The Beaumont children
where three children three siblings one
was the four
4 7 11.
um they went to the beach because back
then listen you just go went no one yeah
my brother and I used to leave the house
at six in the morning and and you can
come back till six in the evening right
and God does what the hell we got up to
you know that was the same way 80s it's
like just be home by 10. just be
whatever yeah yeah just be home for
dinner but so these three kids so these
three kids were were kidnapped from a
crowded Beach
and no one ever saw them again
and they've never caught the guy you
might have my own suspicions because at
one time I wanted to do a movie about it
but I was it was suggested to me that I
should not